papapapa pas par quel bout
je m'appelle et me emile durkheim et
vous qui êtes vous mais bon max weber
mon cher de quel paradigme allez vous
parler l'individualisme méthodologique
et vous même qui avez vous savez moi les
paradigmes
j'aime bien les choses qui reprenne la
société dans leur ensemble
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle vidéo de
la société qu'alors petite vidéo rapide
pour vous présenter quelque chose
d'essentiel pour comprendre les sciences
sociales
c'est la question des paradis les
paradigmes des sciences sociales ses de
suite génériques
[Musique]
question avant de commencer le coeur de
cet exposé que sont les paradigmes je
vais me baser sur la définition
d'olivier martin qui nous propose sa
définition dans les 100 mots de la
sociologie à un petit bouquin un petit
peu peut-être trop complexe déjà pour
des élèves du secondaire
mais pour des élèves évidemment de 1ère
bac qui se justifie pleinement
on nous définit le paradigme comme un
ensemble cohérent d'hypothèses qui
constitue un tout et qui offre aux
scientifiques un point de vue sur les
phénomènes qu'ils étudient une matrice
finalement qui conditionne son regard
une représentation du monde cohérente
qui façonnent sa manière de penser les
phénomènes le paradigme c'est une façon
de voir les choses
il y a aussi des paradigmes en sciences
sociales et c'est ce que je vous propose
d'explorer aujourd'hui nous allons
explorer 5 paradigme des sciences
sociales 5 vision de la société qui se
parfois se complètent et parfois se
contredit pour aborder facilement cette
question des paradigmes
j'ai repris l'idée du pratique des
sciences sociales dans ce manuel on nous
propose en fait sac métaphore ou penser
les paradis la première métaphore gelé
reprise quasi tel quelques du texte
c'est le corps humain l'organisme selon
ce premier paradigme la société est
perçu comme un organisme composé de
différents organes qui vont fonctionner
les uns avec les autres parfois avec
certains dysfonctionnements pour faire
tenir l'ensemble qui est le corps humain
en général ou l'organisme vivant en
général on retrouve dans son pari ce
paradigme certains auteurs comme robert
merton qu'on étudiera ici sera sociaux
tech ou encore emile 2 km qui est
considéré par certains comme
fonctionnaliste puisqu'il s'agit du nom
de ce paradis à seconde métaphore qui va
nous aider à découvrir ce qu'est le
second paradigme gelé un petit peu
traficoter par rapport aux bouquins le
pratique des sciences sociales puisque
je considère le second paradigme c'est
un peu un match de football entre deux
équipes qui tentent de gagner la partie
avec cette précision c'est que certains
matchs sont truquées et que chacun des
acteurs pensent
que le match ne l'est pas le résultat
est ce qu'il est et étant donné que le
match était truqué c'est toujours
l'équipe qui devait gagner qui gagne
mais ceux qui ont perdu crois que c'est
vraiment les meilleurs qui ont gagné je
trouve que cette métaphore est assez
bien tapé que pour comprendre ce
paradigme qui est le paradigme
structuraliste un paradigme aux listes
c'est à dire qu'ils voient la société
vraiment comme quelque chose d'ensemble
qui va contraindre les individus la
société impose des règles aux joueurs de
football qui a eu avec un petit peu les
cartes qu'ils ont en main vont essayer
de remporter le match si on est dans un
paradigme où la société est perçu comme
un champ de confrontation et évidemment
pierre bourdieu est sans doute l'auteur
qui le plus marquant de ce paradigme
mais carmarks autres auteurs illustre
veut plus vieux que bourdieu évidemment
est aussi à classer dans ce paradigme
troisième paradigme il s'oppose
totalement avec le précédent
c'est le paradigme qu'il y ait à la
métaphore du marché sur un marché
qu'elle ait chaque individu va agir en
fonction de ses propres besoins
selon ses propres intérêts va essayer de
trouver les meilleurs produits au
meilleur prix sans se soucier de ce que
font les autres
ça c'est la façon de voir des
scientifiques qui vont être dans le
paradigme de l'individualisme
méthodologique
ils vont utiliser la méthode vraiment
compréhensif rentrer dans les logiques
de chacun dans les croyances de chacun
pour arriver à des comportements
généraux en aucun cas ils ne vont
considérer la société comme quelque
chose qui puisse contraindre les
individus les individus restent libres
et responsables de leurs actes et c'est
rien que leur logique personnelle qui va
faire qu'on va avoir des comportements
collectifs mais qui ne sont que
l'agrégation de chacun des comportements
individuels le quatrième paradigme c'est
le paradigme qui ressemble finalement un
voilier le voilier est sur la mer ou sur
une étendue d'eau et il va être portée
en fonction des vents dominants des
ventes qui peuvent parfois s'opposer et
qui s'oppose aussi au courant qu on
retrouve dans ce paradigme en fait
l'actionnaire isme tout ce champ des
sciences sociales qui va étudier le
changement social et notamment le
changement social du fait des individus
qui s'associent selon leurs intérêts
parfois selon leurs valeurs pour faire
changer les choses
donc par exemple les groupes féministes
ou les antispécistes le cinquième
paradigme c'est le paradigme qui est lié
au théâtre les acteurs sociaux sont sur
une scène et en fonction du jeu des
autres acteurs vont adapter leur propre
jeu pour réaliser la meilleure
prestation et ne pas perdre la face
évidemment pour apparaître de la manière
a plus positif aux yeux des autres c'est
également le contexte du théâtre le
décor qui va contraindre le jeu des
individus ainsi sur une scène de théâtre
avec un décor baroque
les comédiens joueront sans doute d'une
certaine manière dans la société
il en va de même puisque en fonction
d'un type de lait corps nous allons
adopter certains types de comportements
il serait très mal vu évidemment de
commencer à danser dans un funérarium
par exemple et donc le décorum du
funérarium va vraiment imposé le silence
aux individus et la métaphore du théâtre
est assez bien aussi trouvé pour ce
paradigme
j'en ai fini avec ses différents
paradigmes alors j'aimerais vous
préciser d'abord quelques petites choses
il ne faut pas penser que chaque auteur
chaque sociologue chercheur en sciences
sociales va vraiment rentré dans le
moule d'un paradigme il s'agit de
modèles est par définition les modèles
sont des simplifications du réel qui
nous permettent cependant de comprendre
ce même réel donc les auteurs peuvent
être évidemment qui est à plusieurs
paradigme au cours de leur carrière ils
peuvent également évoluer et passer d'un
paradigme à un autre actuellement le
champ des sciences sociales est assez
éclaté dans ses différents paradigmes et
on ne peut pas dire que les chercheurs
ou les sociologues se réclame vraiment
d'un paradigme bien qu' il ya encore des
guerres de chapelle si on peut dire
entre certains de ces paradis par
exemple entre l'individualisme
méthodologique et le structuralisme on
aura quelque chose dit réconciliables
qui ne pourra jamais être dépassé à mon
avis dans le champ des sciences sociales
voilà j'espère que ces vidéos vous
plaisent en tout cas je prends beaucoup
de plaisir à partager tout ça avec vous
alors c'est un partage mais vous aussi
s'il vous plaît partager avec l'ensemble
ben de la chaîne avec tous les gens qui
suivent on n'est pas beaucoup mais il ya
quand même des gens qui suivent très
régulièrement cette chaîne
donc si vous avez des choses à dire des
commentaires on essaie d'y répondre
c'est intéressant parce que ça fait un
petit peu s'apprécie certains concepts
on n'a pas la science infuse moi je suis
pas sociologue docteur en sociologie
je suis juste un prof de secondaire qui
essaient de se dépatouiller dans toutes
ces histoires donc si vous trouvez qu'il
ya des choses qui sont pas assez
précises ben vous le dites si vous aimez
bien vous le dites aussi parce que ça
fait plaisir évidemment un essai ce qui
me nourrit
je dois dire que voilà s'il n'y avait
pas tous ces commentaires positifs et
tout ce qui tourne autour de la chaîne
peut-être que je serai pas aussi motivé
de faire des vidéos si souvent et tout
ça donc franchement alesi et puis voilà
je vous souhaite beaucoup de plaisir
avec les sciences sociales et à très
bientôt pour préparer cet exposé je vous
ai déjà parlé de la bibliographie
utilisé on peut refaire le point sur ces
bouquins que je trouve intéressant pour
un cursus de sciences sociales but
secondaire ou
le pratique des sciences sociales tome 2
est évidemment avec beaucoup d'outils
théoriques mais aussi beaucoup de
documents avec toi on a bien sûr les 100
mots de la sociologie je vous en mets
parlait tu dois reculer un petit peu
julien et enfin ce bouquin si je
voudrais pas parler aujourd'hui mais je
m'en sers beaucoup on trouve parfois
remettre lisez en place il est de
nathalie rigaud qui est professeur de
zoologie allumé stand namur pour les
élèves de première bac si je ne me
trompe guère fils au fait tu te mets
plus ou moins niveau et ici on a
vraiment une initiation à la sociologie
par les sept 7 grands auteurs je
m'intéressais plus grand parce que c'est
pas été plus grands en tout cas cette
hauteur vraiment intéressant de bourdieu
bien sûr on parle de vapeur de wever on
parle de durkheim
il ya des exercices alors où mes
collègues compter sur de sciences
sociales des exercices sont proposées
aussi en ligne avec ou sans obliger
makarem beaumont m'ont un peu près -
revenir mais monsieur j'ai essayé d
évaluation avec ses applications qui
était proposée par nathalie errigo je
vous mets toute façon tu connais
référence ici en commentaire et je dois
dire que ces évaluations se sont assez
bien passé donc en réadaptant évidemment
à nos élèves on sait ces propositions
d'exercice
ça peut marcher et ça peut donner de
très bonnes choses revenaient plus près
non elle écoute bolt
[Musique]